it is quite difficult to run an
international network peace organization
like ipb we have some 300 members with
different specialities some work against
the drones some work on peace education
some work on peace history some work on
the militarization of space or
anti-nuclear anti-nuclear weapons and
also the relation between nuclear
weapons and nuclear energy so combining
the work of many organization is not
always obvious but we think that the top
priority for us for the time being is a
program that we call disarmament for
development and we want to help show
that to different means that if we
disarm we have a better possibility to
develop